hi everyone my name is Ryan Johnson and
I'm a data science adviser here at posit
and I just want to take a few moments to
talk about certain data science
scenarios where you may find posit
connect to be particularly helpful now
most data science teams aim to create
insights that can drive a group company
or an industry forward and maybe your
group today is already using posit
workbench to develop these insights
including shiny apps fast apis quto
documents and much more for our first
scenario have you ever been in a
situation where you needed to easily
share insights with certain groups or
individuals maybe your team has built an
impressive shiny application in R and
you tried to share it with others using
email well your email probably looked
like this where you tried your best to
explain how viewers can install our our
studio packages package versions and get
it running on their personal computers
well it would be much easier if instead
you could provide viewers with a simple
link to the shiny application hosted on
posit
connect you might also need posit
connect if you find that your day is
full of recurring tasks that you need to
complete every hour every day every week
month or even year and here are just
some tasks that posit connect and help
with maybe you need to send a weekly
report to your boss or update a machine
learning model maybe you need to extract
new data from an API and load that data
into a database or any other recurring
job
for our third scenario have you ever
needed to Simply give your data science
insights a secure home maybe you've had
a conversation like this before with a
colleague where someone wants to review
a report but your team can't remember
where that report lives with posit
connect you can now give those insights
a home for our fourth scenario have you
ever been in a situation where someone
had access to a dashboard or report that
they weren't supposed to see with posit
connect you can easily control access
access to your Data Insights especially
if they contain sensitive
information for our last scenario have
you ever created a report application or
dashboard that underwent multiple
revisions and when it came down to
sharing the final version you can't
remember which version is the right one
with posit connect you can publish
different versions of the same asset to
a single location and easily revert back
to a previous version if
needed and those are my top five
scenarios where posit connect can help
your data science team if you'd like to
learn more about posit connect feel free
to reach out to us and we'd love to chat
more